we did a documentary about Ira Glasser
called Mighty Ira um which was my video
team and my prot Nico Pino and Chris
Malby and Aaron Reese put it together
and it's just follows The Life and Times
of um of Ira Glasser the former head of
the ACLU hea if you could just Linger on
that that's a fascinating story oh yeah
who's who amazing um Ira he wasn't a
lawyer um he started working at the n
nyclu New York civil liberties Union
back in I think the 60s he was I think
Robert Kennedy recommended that that he
go in that direction um and he became
the president of the ACLU right at the
time that they were um suffering from uh
defending the Nazis at skoki and Nico uh
and Aaron and Chris put together this
and they'd never done a documentary
before and it came out so so well um and
it tells the story of the Nazis and
skoki tells the story of the case around
it tells the story of the ACLU at the
time and what a great leader Ira Glasser
was and what's one of the things that's
so great is like when you get to see the
Nazis at skoi they come off like the
idiots that you would expect them to
there there's a moment when the when the
rally is not going very well and and the
the leader gets flustered and it almost
seems like he's going to like shout out
kind of like you're you're you're you're
making this Nazi rally into a mockery
and so it showed how actually ing the
Nazis to speak at at ski kind of took
the wind out of their sales like if they
had they the whole movement like
everybody just kind of it all kind of
dissolved after that because they looked
like racist fools that they were they
were you know even Blue's Brothers made
you know jokes about them um and it and
it didn't turn into the disaster that
people thought it was going to be just
by letting them speak and IRC last year
okay so he has this wonderful story
about how Jackie Robinson joined the
Brooklyn Dodgers and how there was a
moment when it was seeing someone an
African-American as on their literally
on their team and how that really got
him excited about the cause of of racial
equality and and that became a big part
of what his life was and I I just think
of that such a great metaphor is
expanding your circle and seeing more
people as being quite literally on your
team is the solution to so many of these
problems and I worry that one of that
one of the things that is just a fact of
life in America is like we do see each
other more as enemy camps as as opposed
to people on the same
team